the message from the polish side was
clear we're protecting our territory
refugees and migrants kept behind wire
fences on the other side
thousands are still in limbo lord the eu
says by a bella russian president intent
on causing another migrant crisis and
destabilizing the union
we have to talk about the effective
blocking of flights from the countries
of the middle east to belarus because we
know that this is only an instrument of
political blackmail and we need to start
diplomatic actions from the european
union from brussels in the capitals of
the countries of the middle east
that call came as the polish border
guard posted a video on twitter
purporting to show migrants running
along the border led by a man wearing
military uniform further evidence many
believe that president alexander
lukashenko is out to cause trouble
seeking revenge for eu imposed sanctions
on belarus
totally groundless artificial
insinuations of irresponsible
politicians the only thing they know how
to do is wave the acts of sanctions
because it is so easy for them it is on
hand just wave and think later about
what to do
what has become a major diplomatic
crisis will not have been helped by
images of planes from russia an ally of
belarus patrolling over its border in a
phone call german chancellor angela
merkel asked president vladimir putin to
intervene calling the treatment of
migrants by belarus inhumane
but many have also questioned the role
of eu nations including poland who've
been accused of pushing asylum seekers
back and denying them access to welfare
we're about three kilometers away from a
major flash point where thousands of
migrants and refugees are trying to gain
access to poland from belarus and it's
the closest we're going to get there's a
state of emergency in place which
prevents journalists and aid agencies
from getting close to the border
lithuania now has imposed similar
restrictions
eu is threatening more sanctions against
belarus and is contemplating financing
physical infrastructure at poland's
border
what no one has the answer to yet is
what happens to the thousands of men
women and children at the center of this
diplomatic and humanitarian crisis
michelle clifford sky news poland